freshly harvested wheat is piling up all
over Ukraine Europe's Bread Basket is
struggling to send its supplies abroad
Alexander has 20 000 tons of high
quality wheat stored and ready to be
shipped
but
it hurts we have been growing this for
one year it's like a child you care for
it you feed it you protect it from
illness after that you bring it home and
now look at it what can we do with it
there have been seven Russian attacks on
ports near Odessa since Moscow pulled
out of the Black Sea grain initiative
making a new deal with Russia to protect
Ukraine's exports increasingly unlikely
Ukraine estimates that Russian attacks
have destroyed more than 200 000 tons of
food in recent weeks with a humanitarian
Corridor the country hopes that
international shipping companies will
sail the vital Port of Odessa again so
the world's food supply can be
guaranteed
last March Ukraine approved an insurance
fund of 500 million dollars for ships
willing to sail but without safety
guarantees from Russia the port barely
functions yeah before the war view was
uh well it was full of trucks rail carts
ships tugboats Ships Come Again coming
out
helling operations loading discharging
vessels and it was full of noise and you
know hustle and bustle of this port big
Port but now it's absolutely quiet
the first successful Journey Through the
Black Sea of container ship Joseph
Schulte stuck in Odessa since the start
of the war is seen as hopeful we are
looking now our international shipping
Society insurance company painting clubs
will react on this situation I think
it's not only about the uh to being
affordable to sell it's about to take
the risk on how to take the risk he
believes only security guarantees will
convince shippers to transport grain
from Ukraine's main Port again this is
important because the ports on the river
Danube they are using now are too small
to export Ukraine's massive grain Supply
right now Green from Ukraine is much
more expensive because the logistics
cost if we open up bigger desk support
again grain will the price for the grain
will go down internationally
meanwhile Alexander tries to help small
farmers to plan new crops but with very
little profit and weed piling up some
wonder whether it's even worth it next
year step fast and Al Jazeera Odessa
region